I'm Jeff Goldblum and these are thirst
thirst treats you oh my god Chris never
was so hot
me being intellectual I would love Jeff
over murder me murder of course being
that's the poetical way of saying you
kill me baby you kill me baby I would
let jeff goldblum redacted my redacted
to fill in your own redacted redactions
I would love good but I'm thinking of
something I would love Jessica Wow geez
I would let jeff goldblum rearrange my
guts any day that man exudes sexy and
expensive I exude sexy and expensive
well what the heck's that mean any
affection that I come to exchange has
never been for recompense I'd be remiss
if I didn't tell you that says no
offense in capitals but I would pay
millions of dollars to have Jeff
Goldblum sit on my face exactly like
this exactly like that I'd be like this
I'd be like this you know things I want
in a man six foot four Libra Jewish what
a Jewish man oscar-nominated actor yes I
was I was dominated oh end is Jeff
Goldblum oh that's me so it is me so
that's that what what she wants in a man
that's me it's a lovely thing to be
appreciated in any in any way Jeff
Goldblum's voice could wake me from a
coma now
come back to a smell Matt she's back
jeff goldblum always looks like he'd
listened deeply to your sorrows and let
you have his most expensive bottle of
wine to make you feel better the word
daddy was made to be used on jeff
goldblum and him alone don't at me
what's that mean you ask someone yes my
calling enough
oh don't at me don't at me okay accept
it I accept it why is jeff goldblum so
attractive he's 30 or so years older
than me and I'm a lesbian
but he gets me hot and bothered and
bothered his trademark why is bothered
hey yeah singing the back of this uber
on the 134 thinking about my sexual
awakening aka
Jeff Goldblum wearing those leather
pants in Jurassic Park you like leather
clothing sure I don't know you well
enough never mind
I want Jeff Goldblum to stroke my hand
and talk about microscopic variations in
the skin like he did with Laura Dern's
character in Jurassic Park oh and look
at the tiny hairs in your hands and
imperfections imperfections not nothing
not bad by a him prevent look at that
look at that that was the most fun I
ever had in my whole life I mean golly
very very flattering
[Music]